Howdy, y'all!
Howdy, howdy!
Welcome, welcome, welcome!
Hello, everybody!
Today I'm purple.
Today...
Today I decided to be purple.
I'm purple today.
Howdy.
Oh, princess.
Oh, my gosh.
If I ever have an ojo-sama that I could call princess, I would say it.
I would go to her and be like, oh, princess.
Oh, princess.
Why is she Orpil?
Because...
Because the thumbnail!
Who are you?
Aminto!
It's my birthday and Taco Tuesday!
Toxtrinx!
Happy birthday!
I love my cringe-o-she.
I think I was thinking so much for that tiny gift.
Thank you!
Does this mean we have purple doki?
This is not her...
This is not about her.
Read the rules.
Do not mention other streamers.
Unless I bring them up first.
Gosh, I don't know.
Ask her.
If you want purple dokey, you're asking the wrong gal.
I volunteer for the role of poinsers.
Oh, poinsers.
Princess.
Princess, it's me, your maid.
It's time to wake up, Princess.
Princess, may I brush your hair?
Hmm.
Princess, let me help you change out of your nightgown, Princess.
Princess, it's time to bathe.
Princess, let me...
Let me...
Let me, let me scrub your back for you, princess.
Don't even whiff your little delicate finger.
What the heck is going on?
Don't worry, that's me.
If I, okay, so I'm a maid cafe maid, right?
But this is if I were to be like a maid in like a real mansion.
Jell!
Mint is a.
color so no i'm lilac i hope you pay your debt thanks meido minto cute though oh
bustin pride turtles did you know my kamiyoshi is debuting a new alpha in less than a week she's also almost at 400k subs actually guys i have a confession to make It's pretty good that I didn't make it to 400k.
Because...
Eh, sooner, I mean.
Actually, the cover isn't done yet.
The video is not done yet.
I was just being like, Oh, maybe I could get there.
Maybe...
It'll incentivize people...
But the video's not done.
It'll be done next week.
And hopefully I reach 400k by then.
So...
Hopefully I reach it by then.
And then we will...
I will...
I'll upload it.
That time Minto overestimated herself.
We gotta unsub.
What do you mean?
Overestimate.
You're just too good.
What do you mean?
So you were lying to us.
No!
It'll come out when I hit 400k.
It might be just a few days later.
It might just be a little later.
Then you...
Imagine if I had hit 400k last week.
You would have had to wait two weeks.
You would have had to unsubscribe.
No, no, no.
Don't unsubscribe.
401k special.
My birthday is Thursday.
I don't know if I could catch stream.
Yeah, actually.
Well, Thursday is also a collab, so it would be hard for me to say happy birthday anyway.
JT, happy birthday.
Just play this on Thursday.
Happy 399k subs.
It's somewhat of a special.
Yeah, Eggie.
Get the boarder kid down so he can be scabbed.
That's my middle name, baby.
Mint scam phantom.
Mint scab tub.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Common color swap skin minto.
Did you guys see I'm a Uma Musume?
Also, oh my gosh, thank you guys so much for all the super chats.
You never promised an instantaneous release so far.
That's true.
That's so true.
The hair looks good in that color.
Thank you.
What if we all unsub till it's out?
No!
She's gaslighting.
us.
Donating to the 400k fund.
Is this like my 401k?
I don't need that anymore though.
I'm dead.
Umaminto!
Yeah!
Did you see?
Uh, what was the worst statement?
Hold on.
What was it?
Was it mint of the maid or maid of the mint?
I can't remember.
made of the mint
made of the mint is a horse I saw people being like I posted this on Twitter in case you're just like I don't know what you're talking about posted a screenshot Snuffy sent me a DM she was just like she slid into my DMs sneaky raccoon she slid into my DMs and she was just like meito look at this thing I discovered while searching horses and it was a horse from 1897 named made of the mint that horse is dead and I saw some people being like ah it's dead oh no and I'm like yeah but that's that's literally me I'm dead too tomorrow I plan on plopping the big question to my special someone Can I get your blessing?
Now what time is your next dream so I can mentally prepare myself?
Wait, huh?
What do you mean?
Wait, do you want me to give you the blessing now or next dream?
Why the long face?
Wait, I'm confused by the timing.
You need it now?
Did I say plopping?
Oh, it does say popping.
I was like, oh, we're plopping the question.
We're just like a chunk of meat on the table.
I thought for real.
I thought that's what she meant because it was a heavy question.
And you're plopping
it on the table.
You get it!
Do you understand my vision?
Jesus.
Sorry.
I'm crying.
Okay, anyway.
Anyway.
What was I saying?
I don't remember anymore.
Horse confirmed.
Oyse Ningen.
Send me that shit, Murphy.
What the hell?
Good bit.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it was a good bit, right, everybody?
I said you're...
Yeah, you said I'm a dead horse.
Continuing with this bit would be beating a dead horse.
You love it.
Ooh, glue factory.
Then you could eat me.
Turn me to glue!
I will be consumed by some curious child.
Some child that is in probably...
What grade did you guys eat glue?
Sashimi?
No, I'm too thin.
I don't have enough, I don't have enough fat on me.
I'm too skinny.
You never did?
Really?
I saw an episode of the Powerpuff Girls and the kid ate glue, but they made fun of him for it.
But I also thought, well, it looks, the kid just makes it look so appetizing.
I never stopped.
I just kind of want to try it.
We all ate glue, right?
We all, we all...
Let's make a song out of it.
I ate glue.
And so did you.
We all ate glue.
Yes, that's so true.
Glue plus crayons is our face.
What does a huffing glue do?
How do you huff the glue?
You sniff the glue?
It smells fine.
For you I'll eat glue.
Ah!
Don't do that!
Oh really?
Huffing glue gets you...
Wait, really?
What if we all start a glue-eating party?
I see a lot of people that have never eaten glue before.
Depends on the glue.
I...
I was about to say I ate.
I only use non-toxic glue.
What does your glue smell like?
It smelled like...
Glue has a very specific smell, no?
Do not huff or eat glue.
Yeah, everybody, let's not eat glue.
We're apparently huff the glue.
Don't sniff glue.
This is your PSA.
It's like those PSAs when you're a kid, they're just like...
They're like, cigarettes are bad.
Getting...
the 400k today so we can cancel her for not having to cover out when you hit 400k you won't give me the 400k today you won't do it you can't give me the 400k if I delete my channel haha jokes on you get caught aren't horses in Japan more likely to become sashimi Perhaps.
Well, I got you.
Would you, would it be better to sniff glue or gas?
Oh, I like the smell.
I, oh my gosh, I love going into like home, like a, what's it called?
Like a, the store is where you get all the wood and the plants.
Um, like the renovation store.
Like a Home Depot?
Yeah, a hardware store!
A hardware store!
I was trying to think of more vague.
Home Depot is a specific place.
Logan, thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Bye.
Um, yeah, the Home Improvement stores.
I like going to those places.
They smell so good.
You guys think that too?
It smells good.
I love that smell.
Yeah, the weird owl song.
Wait, what do you mean?
There's a weird owl song about it.
It's like such a specific smell, like about, like it's like also the wood and all, I guess, the rubber and...
Hardware store!
Wait, I want to listen to it.
Can I, real quick?
If you want a really good smell, open the bags inside a new Lego set and smell that.
Really?
Oh, I've been really wanting a new, um, there was a Lego set I saw that I really thought about getting.
Oh, I remember what it was.
It was, um, it was a, like, a little gotcha.
Hold on.
I can't make the, the game shut up, so I'm just, but I'm gonna listen to this song.
Weird Al Hardware Store.
And I bought Tyson's house!
Thank you so much for five years and thank you!
a hardware store.
Oh my gosh, if I search it, weird out comes up.
Is there a music?
Oh, there is a music video.
Okay.
Sorry, I have to turn it off for you guys.
You actually...
Will I get...
You don't think I'll get caught.
Well, actually, I get caught all the time.
Who cares if it's...
I get caught.
Like, so many of my streams are demonetized.
Obviously, the door knows that's your money is not going to to the ether but you know i don't make money off of a lot of like views that's the way my resident evil 6 game play or gameplay uh playthrough got got by the copyright and it was hold on let me see if i can find it what it what it
um hold on I think I still have the email what why it's so silly it's actually so silly this video cannot be monetized copyrighted copyrighted content has been detected in your video content used Resident Evil 6 Leon gameplay part 2 content owners Capcom I'm sorry I did Resident Evil 6 Leon Gameplay Part 2 in my video!
No!
But I don't know if it's actually Capcom because it's like doesn't seem like Lego vending machine does look pretty darn cool.
Just know it's on perpetual back order so it'll take a bit to get Oh no, I saw it in a store.
I go to actual Lego stores and I saw it.
I just bought and built Lego Soundwave.
He's so effing cool with arms and super poseable.
Comes with a ravage and laser beacon.
They all transform.
What?
Wait, there's Lego Transformers?
I saw Weird Alive last month and I feel like if he personally knew you, he'd want you to listen to hardware stores so he didn't care.
Okay.
Yeah, I honestly don't care about the copyright kind of stuff.
As long as I don't get a strike on my channel.
Josh, thank you so much for the 20 years.
Thank you.
but sorry I can't make the game shut up so this is a weird Al hardware store I'm not gonna do the music video I will just listen to the song what's in a parody of
oh it's original yeah got
the bolts and the screws
Happy!
This is so relatable!
Yeah!
Oh!
This song sounds so hard to sing.
I know, right?
Oh my gosh.
I understand the idea.
enthusiasm though
I'm so I'm
karaoke let me see
Fizz Okay Next karaoke
Fizzy You know I think I realized I've never listened to weird owls like original music now that i think about it i think that was my first time ever hearing one of his songs that like was his song such a good song i was wow psycho optimist prime bumblebee and sound wave all just came out august oh so really recently all transformed with minimal parts removed almost 200 that's crazy hold on i gotta look it up
Lego Transformers.
Oh, they...
Oh, they look good.
Oh, no.
Why would you tell me...
Oh, wait, they look so good!
No, why would you tell me this?
Play the game.
I know, I'm sorry.
I'm yapping.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Okay, we're going to play the game.
It's been 30 minutes and I have just been sitting here.
And also listening to Weird Al.
Woo!
I just want to talk so much when I haven't talked to, you know, all these, like, extra breaks I've been doing.
It's, like, making me always want to just all the time with you guys.
Because I don't...
I have so much...
Everything built up on my days off, you know.
Putting off loan payments to buy Legos.
To real.
Can't believe that I'm in shoes.
Oh yeah, the owl generated music.
Only 30 minutes yapping.
Yeah, sorry to whoever said that.
I don't know if you were being serious or not.
But I think you've been...
You've been...
outvoted.
You've been voted off the island.
No, we'll play, though.
Let's see.
Okay.
New debt, baby, loan charge.
Okay, so this is a game where you um, you are fishing to pay off your debt, and then a magical fish comes and gives you an eyeball that makes you find more magical fish and they're worth they're worth money I think I think it's like dredge maybe yeah I was up with like fishing games and like horror I forgot my hat wait let me put it on real quick let me put on my hat one second give me a moment I put on my hat
I completely forgot.
I turned purple and forgot everything.
Where is it?
Okay, I found it.
It's my fishing hat.
Lucky, let's play the game.
Let's go fishing, baby.
New debt.
Loaning money.
How much money are we getting?
The lone shark lent you a pile of money.
Just a big old pile.
Now he wants it back with interest.
No, no interest.
Don't be interested in me.
You have to work all night.
Every night.
You have no choice.
Your debt is...
Oh, oh, it's still going up.
Oh, it's still going up.
Oh, oh.
This fish better be worth 100,000 bucks each.
Fish as much as you can.
Oh.
Okay.
How do I fish?
Ooh.
I got my beers.
Holy gulp.
My gosh.
I got a little bell.
I'm on the Vida Nova.
Beer o'clock, baby.
Yeah.
Oh.
This isn't so bad.
Everybody.
Oh, wait.
I'm going to move you guys over just a smidge so that we can see the price better.
There you guys go.
Wow, this is actually so nice.
I would be fishing every night if it were like this.
Look, not a soul out here.
Except for me, of course.
Wow, it's pretty, isn't it?
here?
Oh, shut up.
Is that what I think that is right there?
You guys see that?
I think that's a ghostbuster.
Maybe I'm not welcome here.
Fishing logbook.
Fishing notes scribbled on torn out page margins.
Ah, this is some fishing music.
the line at least eight meters if you're too close nothing bites oh the fish either struggles or rests when it rests pull without fear when struggles pull too but watch the line tension if the line tension hits the max the line breaks when you feel it's about to snap let go it's kind of cut off a little bit sorry don't repeat his his mistakes who's he My box,
oh fish.
You need a gutted fish.
And I saw some blood over here.
Oh, this is the gutting board.
Okay, guys.
Let's...
Fish!
Oh, just above eight meters.
Oh, any fish around?
Oh, oh, yeah, they really are.
They're around.
I'm just a little... Oh!
I'm just a little...
Little guy in the water.
Where's the fish?
Uh.
Oh, shoot.
How do I pull?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, I'm pulling.
I'm pulling.
Don't get it too high.
Oh, my gosh.
How do I...
How the hell...
What am I pressing?
I can't tell.
Is it left click or is it...
Is it WASDA?
Nothing seems to be working.
I'm at the fish.
his mercy quite honestly oh I I got him when caught it grinds its teeth oh
come here fishy I'm so sorry for you I must put you on the gutting ward oh it's good gruesome.
This is the fishy reality.
Oh, there goes my debt lowering.
The lure... No, I want to pick up the bottles that are rolling around.
Hold on.
Let's see a different song.
I like this one.
I don't actually quite understand how the fishing... Oh!
Oops.
No, no, no, no.
Come back, come back.
I think it's left click.
Oh, yeah!
This might be the longest stream ever, everybody.
Oh, oh.
We have a little fish.
There they are.
Come on in.
My lure is nice and bright.
I don't understand it.
I think I just left click.
Oh my gosh.
More tension.
No, no.
Somehow.
it works it's a mackerel how'd you know it is a fish rip rich it is a fish rip
thank you so much for the five gift thank you it is a fish rip rich and lipids
Ripsaba, actually, though.
But she is a mackerel, isn't she?
Now I think about it.
What game would you recommend for someone to get into MGS?
Metal Gear Solid 1!
There goes my debt.
Oh, I'm not very good at this.
Hold on.
Let's try again.
I think I...
There we go.
What?
It was in the red.
You guys saw that, no?
Oh, the blue is the max.
Okay, just kidding.
Just kidding, just kidding.
Oh, oh, someone's perusing.
Oh, he's got his own theme song.
Where is he?
Oh, he's ugly.
Oh, we're pulling you in.
I hear my music.
Come on in.
I'm pulling you in.
I'm pulling it...
Jackpot!
It has only one eye.
It's Dfish.
He has one eye.
Alright, buddy.
You're getting gutted.
That hurts!
Get it off, get it off, get it off!
Angler, you've caught me.
I'm a magic fish, but I can't leave until I've repaid my debt.
He's just like me.
Private property is sacred.
And now I belong to you.
This is the beginning of your fairy tale.
Want to see how it goes?
I could just gut him.
We'll play the game.
Then turn the page.
Oh!
He just poofs away.
A puff of smoke.
Oh!
My name is Caglioso.
Magic fish, sea vet, and giver of advice.
when someone young like you catches me they deserve a reward it's the only way i can free myself and i'm not talking about a bouquet of flowers the magic fish coglios coglios my dear angler i bring you prosperity now i'm gonna open my mouth inside you'll find a tiny little It's mine.
It fell a long time ago.
Cal...
Caluso...
Caluso?
Now, I thought he wanted a big old kiss.
It might look like fish waste to you, but it's a powerful artifact.
Hook it on your line like bait.
Oh.
Oh!
I got achievement.
A little help.
Damn.
You wear it well.
Oh my gosh, he's playing.
learning with me.
Now go and fish.
You'll see.
Okay.
I wear it well, huh?
Oh, I did it again.
What the heck?
That was in the middle.
I'm gonna go up.
Ah, yeah.
20.
20 meters.
Oh.
Who's eyeing me?
Who are you?
Who are you, pretty baby?
It sounds kind of spooky in here, no?
Kind of...
The music is like... not the music, the ambience.
How it sounds so much like you're underwater, you know?
It's kind of spooky.
Oh, I hear my music!
The sea is spooky, you think so?
You were the fish on the hook.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna make it out of here.
We're gonna make it out of here, everybody.
You have to go.
I thought he was talking to me.
I'm sprinting.
Oh.
I think I got...
Is this a parrotfish?
I actually didn't see what it was saying.
Nice, huh?
The scales on that fish?
Pure gold.
Worth as much as it weighs.
Eh, eh.
This was my reward for a top-notch angler like you.
Now we're even, and I'm free.
So I'm taking back my...
No!
Don't take back your eye.
As much as I'd love to leave it with you, it's my property.
And private property is sacred.
Aw, man.
We have to go back to a stupid 15-pound fish.
Look, not to pry.
But I've seen you fish in here for weeks now.
Megalodon.
Got him.
We should have gutted him and then taken his eye.
Day in night.
Day in.
You get it.
You're working this hard because you have to, right?
Money troubles.
It's none of your beeswax.
Sorry.
You're right.
I've already taken the liking to you.
I worry.
I think he likes me, guys.
You remind me of my younger self.
Minus the gills, of course.
Not in your business.
Nacho cheese.
Fairyfish, but I only see why.
Oh, don't.
Alright, I'm off.
But if you ever need help, ring that nice bell hanging behind you.
I'll come by to check on you.
Goodbye, angler.
No, mister.
Oh.
Oh, is that the phone?
The phone?
Hold on.
I'm busy.
I'm fishing.
Okay.
I don't think anything's...
coming i'm working here excuse me oh angler you recognize me right no why is this one like no no non non non
so that's how it is we're only friends when i have to lend you money for your little boat but when it's time to pay back you act like nothing's wrong whatever i know you're out fishing again tonight good on you for working hard i am working hard thank you for that kusuba Thank you!
Nice hair.
You like my hat too?
But it's been too long.
Return to port?
Pull into yours.
You need to bring me all the money to the usual spot.
I've got 45 minutes?
Don't screw around.
Wait!
That's a real- that's a real timer!
Whoa!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Ring a ling ling!
Why'd you call me, angler?
You're looking for more golden fish?
What's going on?
Isn't what I gave you enough?
Bro, I'm in so much trouble!
Lay it out for me.
The lone shark's demanding all his money back tonight.
Is that so...
You know a thing or two about fishing, that's for sure.
But when it comes to money, you're clueless.
Look at the mess you're in.
I'll lend you the eye.
Enough so you can nearly pay off your debt.
Nearly!
Why are you so stingy?
Come on!
But I'm not doing it for free.
I see you've got a nice crate of beer.
Bring me one.
Oh, yeah.
A cold bottle of beer.
Oh, yeah, a nice cold one with the fish.
Saltwater leaves your sword.
Your throat sore.
I can't read, everybody.
There you go.
You can have as many as you want.
Finally.
Working hard or hardly working.
I'm working hard.
Wait, the timer is still going down.
Oh my gosh.
Finally.
I can't take it anymore.
I have to drink it now.
Do you think that our fishy friend here was a human?
Didn't the book say don't make the past mis- Don't make his mistakes?
Do you think our fishy friend here...
Was it past angler, maybe?
Beer in exchange for 700k euro.
Open it and pour it into my mouth.
Okay.
Um.
Into the mouth.
Nice and cold.
Just how I like it.
You're better as a waiter than as an angler, I guess.
I am a maid, after all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here's the eye.
Thank you.
Beer battered fish.
Take good care of it.
It's just a rental.
You can go.
Go.
Oh.
Whoa.
It was so loud.
Oh my god.
Go fish now.
Golly, mister.
Oh, okay.
Ah, I drank it on accident.
Okay.
I was going to give it to him.
Maybe he's not thirsty.
Ooh, it's freaky looking.
Did you guys see that?
I think if we caught that, if we sold that, it would be crazy bucks.
Hello?
Yeah, I'm not really one of those people that's afraid of the sea, you know?
Can I move at all?
Oh, oh!
We're being viewed!
Hello!
Oh, there it is!
Ooh, its lips look like really...
Like, realistic.
Like a human's...
Human lips, you know?
Oh, I'm...
holding i'm holding i don't know how to fish do you want low tension or high tension but obviously you don't want too high of tension it will it will snap keep seeing a ghost in the bottom right of the screen the eye doesn't belong to the fish
interesting sushi
Whoa, 24!
My PB!
What is that noise?
What is all this noise?
Oh my gosh.
I don't like it.
It sounds huge.
I said I'm not afraid of the ocean, but...
What if I am?
But like, when I go swimming and stuff, I'm not afraid of the ocean.
afraid of like my feet not you know when he can't touch the bottom or whatever i hear i hear our music we're safe come on a peacock bash you can't escape death i'm not trying to can a girl why do i have debt as a ghost this is messed up this is so messed up
Rental's over!
I'm taking back the eye.
Private property is sacred.
Why does it keep saying that?
Fish got walked with legs.
It looked like a frog.
The student loans.
No!
No, don't take back my eye, please.
You've made yourself a nice little staff.
You certainly won't need my help anymore.
Actually, I think I do, though.
But in the unlikely case you need me, ring the bell.
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
They're calling me again.
It's me, Angler.
Change of plans.
You have to bring me double the amount!
I was still at a million, though.
Please!
I protest.
Wait, you think I'm your charity case?
I ask for as much as I want.
And anyway, it's not only up to me.
I also have debts to pay.
Oh, it's not even just like...
It's not even double...
Oh my god.
Listen, I know it's a shitty situation.
So you might want to...
I don't know.
Run away.
Wait.
anchor shall we say don't do it you may run away but your debt stays and i have to go ask for the money from people you know this is so evil think about the people you care about people who don't even know what shit you've gotten into imagine their faces when they hear the doorbell they find me Do I have anyone that cares about me?
I've bought a boat all day and night.
If they don't have the money either, things get really bad.
Do you want it to go like that?
Yes, no, fuck off.
I kind of want to be a little Frenchman.
Fuck off.
I'm not the one who makes the rules.
For what it's worth, I'm sorry.
I hope you're sailing towards the harbor.
Ah!
Fish!
Wait, there was... Did you guys see... There was a... There was a head there!
Did you guys see that?
Sorry.
Ugh!
Again, angler?
Did I imagine that?
What head?
No, you guys didn't see?
You really can't do anything without me, can you?
How much of that debt is still left?
Like, an unimaginable amount.
I'm gonna tell him.
So he knows the real...
I need the I for as long as I need it.
Damn.
I've met hungry sharks, but yours is starving.
How do you even rack up that much debt?
That's a great question.
No offense, but come on.
You seemed like a sharp one.
But now I realize you have no clue how to work in this business.
You did everything wrong.
Do you agree?
Hey, answer me.
Oh, I only have 35 minutes.
But if we start getting big fish, it should be fine, no?
I'll just agree.
I don't want to be a quitter.
Umamusame addiction, so true.
Yes, what?
Yes, I did.
Everything wrong.
Exactly.
You reeled in Cogliuso.
Here, only by sheer dumb luck.
Go on, say it.
What do you want me to say?
Oh, what does that have to do with anything?
That has everything to do with it.
We need to define our terms.
You want to waste more time?
No, no, repeat what I told you.
I fished up Caglioso by sheer dove luck.
Now we can get down to business.
This debt isn't something we fix over a couple of beers.
But since I pity you, here's an offer, okay?
I'll sell you my eye.
Just think endless goldenfish, okay?
Pay off your debts tonight.
Become a millionaire by morning.
But in return, I want something valuable.
An eye for an eye.
I want something valuable.
Something like...
Your eye!
I called it.
I know, I know.
You're thinking how gross that is.
But I don't make the rules.
Who's making the rules then?
I run a free enterprise.
Not a charity.
Private property is sacred.
It should be valued.
You're the one who got yourself into debt.
You've already got the gutting knife.
Think about it.
No rush.
We've got all the time in the world, right?
We don't!
Oh!
Am I getting cursed?
We can't go back without the full payment.
No, the onboard phone.
Nah, that big thing was a drive by burp fish.
Oh, that was from 15 minutes ago.
Oh, my gosh.
You're hesitant?
Let me help you.
Gowd out your eye.
It's the best investment you can make in this life.
How do I...
Oh, I need the knife, I guess.
Do you want to gouge your eye out?
See!
I have my eyes.
Ah, you can kind of see it behind me.
Here you go.
That wound's burning now.
But you did the right thing.
Trust me.
Here's my eye.
No, your eye.
Yeah, an eye for an eye, mister.
Oh, you wear it so well.
What a nice shiny new eye.
Smile, you can pay off all your debt now.
I'm staying here with you.
I can't do it alone.
That much is clear.
Oh, right?
Answer me.
I can't do it alone!
I'm just... I'm just...
I'm just giving this guy everything he wants.
Oh my... You can see the right side is now like all red and stuff.
Oops, that was not a good throw.
I need to look up more.
Gamers don't look up.
Oh my god!
That was kind of freaky!
What about his eyes?
Oh, someone's viewing us.
Is this like a speed dating?
Here he comes!
Love your purple outfit, very royal.
Oh, thank you!
We still need a lot of fish though.
have to be fast on the on the gutten and the that was a good amount on the everything oh hello hello oh there we go he's too small this guy's tiny
okay here we go look pb 24.3 let's go 10 thank you so much for the 10 gifted thank you oh oh
is that our guy are we gonna catch him guys i think we're in trouble
hello any fish here we go i like how it's like this guy is coming for you coming in hot oh he's oh this guy's made of pure gold This guy is the golden fish.
Instead of a goose that lays golden eggs, I have an eyeball that gives me golden fish.
I guess they would be attracted to, like, the shininess of the eye, I suppose.
Oh, yeah, baby!
I'm scared to turn around.
I feel like I'm going to see a spooky thing in the side there.
Oh.
I feel like my ship's haunted now.
Watching you fish.
I really wonder how you thought buying a boat was a good idea.
I mean, you know you fish like shit, right?
Like Saruzo.
He was just like you.
Oh, maybe that's the guy.
We're being compared to.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm just getting better and better, you guys.
25.5.
What do you mean I fish like shit?
I got 25 meters away.
We're gaming.
28 minutes.
Wait, does the game end in 28 minutes?
Johnny, yes, Papa.
Catching fish, no, Papa.
your eye out no papa then open your mouth ha ha ha the eye belongs to suruzo wait I forgot to read the one from before too uh-oh wait fish who's telling me this information I like watching the Numbered, go down.
98 subs.
98?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
My eye!
A giant hand snatched your eye?
That bastard just won't quit.
Who?
That bastard?
Nothing, nothing.
Don't worry, you won't see him again.
I'll tell my associate to keep him away from now on.
Let's get back to business.
Saruzo took his eye, yeah.
Back to business.
Yeah, back to business.
Angler, you lost the eye.
You were myself?
But lucky for you, I've got to spit.
How many eyes you have?
But as you know, well, no, I don't do anything for free.
Luckily for you, I'm a bit hungry.
If you let me eat one of your golden fish, golden-ish, I'll give you a new eye.
Wait, but my dad!
Yeah, whose eye is this anyway?
Who else would it be?
It's mine.
How many eyes does a fish have?
It's mine because I bought it.
I keep a reserve.
Thought you were the first I did business with?
I told you I'm an entrepreneur.
Some invest in oils, some in gold.
I invest in eyes.
Enough about my business.
Let's talk about yours.
Do you accept my offer?
Oh, I only have 25 minutes.
What if I decline?
I need all the fish I can get.
Yes, this is some fishy business, eh?
Can we gut him?
I know.
I'll just keep going.
My belly's calling.
Better not lose this one.
No, the number go up!
No, number go up!
Actually, lose it and I'll have another snack.
I've got plenty in stock.
How many times is this guy taking people's eyes?
Alright.
Nope.
We don't want any hand coming from the deep.
24!
It just beeped at me.
Also, sorry if that was so loud, the noise.
I tried to turn it down when it happened.
It's loud for me, too.
Hello?
Hello, tasty fish.
You're not tasty, you're you're wealthy.
Ooh, this one's pretty.
I like the markings.
I like how the eyes are shadowed, though.
We have our Hentai protagonist fish here.
No!
Oh my gosh, I let the tension get He was too high!
He was right there!
I messed up!
No!
Our fish!
Oh my gosh, I'm such an idiot.
Come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come!
Oh, he's back, he's back!
He couldn't resist the temptation.
He says, yeah, I know.
I shouldn't be hanging out with you, but...
You just got such a pretty eye, a little lady.
I'm
careful now, I'm careful.
You
guys think we'll make it?
Oh yeah, yeah.
Black spotted grunt.
Saruza wants his eye back!
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, please.
Please, please, please.
I have so much more.
It's a fish.
Here, we get the best fish up here.
This is my best throw.
Wow, it really is my best throw.
At 28 meters.
That's crazy.
Yes.
You can't resist.
Oh my god, I'm just getting a hole.
Oh my god.
But full of...
Fish.
Come on, come on.
Actually, how much is that even?
Two million?
I can't tell.
I'm staring at the little white bar.
Little white bar going back and forth.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, high tension.
Attention.
Low tension.
High tension.
Come on.
bored, buddy.
Come home.
To Papa.
Stop.
Oh, this butt got in my way!
Oh.
That was my best throw, too.
This butt got in my way!
Stop yanking so hard.
I'll just...
Sometimes...
Wait, this is a new sometimes I yank it so hard I ripped this guy's crazy looking wait I want to see what this is wait this guy's crazy looking oh
I'm not paying any attention to him or my money oh
is he coming in I can't hear our music yet
barracuda holy cow you'll up on the bottom of the sea why
oh barracuda is going so slow i'm trying to cut this thing open but he's too long am i missing a spot oh oh it's bright
siruzo had your same attitude your daddy gave you some good advice minky
everything.
Never willing to listen to learn from those who really know shit.
And look how you end up.
What?
I've been giving you everything that I want or what that you wanted.
In the jaws of the lone shark.
I don't need to hear your lectures.
I understand I'm in a predicament.
Unbelievable.
You did it.
Oh my gosh, that was it.
You have all the gold you need to pay off the debt.
If I were you, I'd run to the cabin and start the engine right now.
Why are you saying it like that?
There are people on the ground waiting.
But always remember, if you have a problem, you don't know how to solve.
If you don't know what to do.
Mint cranking her bowl of the catch fish.
Ring the bell and I'll come help you.
I don't see how you could screw things up again.
But you've shown me more than once tonight that you're not exactly sharp.
So I won't say goodbye.
Oh, no, please.
Okay.
I need a drink before I talk to this guy.
Just drive the bow?
I should have, right?
You still haven't shown up.
Be honest.
Do you have that money?
Yes?
Then push the engine to the max and teleport yourself here or teleport the money off.
For all I care.
I don't want this end badly.
I really don't.
So be on time.
I'm going.
Oh.
He won't mind if I'm like a few minutes late, right?
Can I fish while I...
No.
It's the same as before.
Um.
This is so peaceful, though, no?
No.
this is so nice ring the bell what if i tell him though hey what's up what do you mean you're running late what did you buy that costly autopilot for if you still show up late christ on a bike do you realize the position you're putting me in i would have given you another month but my bosses got tired of waiting you're dead if you don't make it on time i shouldn't have lent you this freaking money why the hell did you go solo Listen,
pray to San Gennaro, clever stream title.
Pray to the moon, pray to the sea.
But get here before time runs out.
Angler, hold on a moment, I'm thinking.
Was it 2008 or 2011?
I'll let him figure it out.
2011.
I've been thinking about Seruzo, that angler I told you about.
Yeah, it's 2011, you guys.
If it were 2011, right, like if you were teleported back to 2011 right now, what would you do?
Are some of you even alive then?
Invest in Bitcoin!
Why are so many of you saying that?
people immediately back on back on back on
so funny they're not wrong it was just so it wasn't like uh i would make sure i studied harder so i passed that exam that i was really sad i didn't get an a in or oh i would i i would i would be brave and i would ask that person out No, Bitcoin, Bitcoin,
Bitcoin!
Okay, Saruzo was buried in debt too.
Actually, you know what?
Let me tell you a story.
Uh, we only have 15 minutes.
Let's interrupt him.
I'll stop you right there.
You called me because you need my help again, right?
The terms are simple then.
I listen to you if you listen to me first.
Fair, right?
Now shut up.
Once upon a time, there was Saruzo.
He was a young man who wanted to live off the...
the sea and fish.
But he wasn't born into a rich family.
He couldn't just buy a boat with his own money.
He went to work for a rich captain.
But according to Saruso, the captain was useless.
He's captain only because he was born rich, Saruso used to say.
In the end, he quit.
He wanted to do things his way.
To captain his own fishing boat.
He had no money, but he had a friend who could lend him some.
A lone shark.
So he went into debt.
What do you think of Saruso's choice?
Quitting because he worked for an idiot.
Wait, is that what I did?
Siruzo was Well, that's what I did Apparently Born with Bitcoin in his mouth Invest in mint coin Yeah, yeah, yeah Stocks are rising He was wrong So you condemn Siruzo's choice What about yours then?
With the lone shark's money Siruzo finally bought his own fishing boat A piece of junk like yours just to be clear but he was so happy too bad reality caught up with him fast being captain of your own boat has its honors but mostly its burdens so Ruzzo had no more set hours no more steady paycheck the lone shark though was always on time demanding payments too bad the fishing season didn't go well that's the sea one day it fills your nets the next it pisses in your face some of you guys should become anglers I would know.
I'm a sea veteran.
Even Saruzo's former captain knew it.
And he was rich, so we didn't care about a bad season.
Saruzo, he never saw it coming.
He didn't make a dime.
He kept piling up debts just to keep his boat.
Ended up working like a slave.
All day long, every single day, until one night he caught me.
Man, he was so proud to have me on his stupid hook.
I thought I was some rare catch, that idiot.
I bought my freedom with a golden fish.
Saruzo wanted more.
We made a trade, then another.
Fish after fish he was willing to give more and more.
He just didn't get the value of things.
In the end, he even sold me his eye.
Wait, this guy is just like me.
The same eye you've got on your line!
Oh!
Why Saruzo is...
Reaching from the depths?
You said it was yours and you lost it.
But it was mine.
Saruzo sold it to me fair and square.
It was my property.
Oh no, the property is sacred.
One last question.
Who was the fish caught on the hook that night?
Me or Saruzo?
Saruzo?
Good.
And tonight...
Just kidding.
No need to answer.
Glary tale's over.
So what favor do you need this time?
Deliver all the golden fish to your lone shark on time?
Wait, how do we know the...
Obviously the fish has magical powers, but how would we even know the fish could do that?
You didn't think about deadlines.
Kid, this job's not for you.
I can deliver the fish, but that'd be a real miracle.
I want your boat.
know.
Doesn't feel good hearing that, huh?
But seriously, why do you care about that piece of junk?
You've got my eye.
Tomorrow you'll be sitting by the sea catching enough gold to buy five boats.
Come on, I'm helping you out.
This little boat isn't even worth the upkeep.
Ficious scammer, me thinks.
Perhaps.
Do yourself a favor, sell it to me, then clear you're dead.
Just like Ceruso did.
No.
Think it over, please.
I can wait, and I will.
But you know it's your best interest.
Don't check in out now.
Oh, my bow!
Vita Nova!
Oh, my bow.
Oh, the beer cans.
Oh, oh, I have ten minutes.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
The moon has gone dark.
I don't think that's the clouds.
Okay.
I'll give you my boat.
Do you want to sell me this rust bucket and get yourself out of this mess?
Yes.
How are we getting home without a boat?
Yeah, I'm wondering that too.
Good for you.
Fish delivered.
You made it, Angler.
You don't need me anymore.
Or my boat.
Goodbye.
Oh, it was.
I was behind the clouds.
Angler, I don't know how you did it.
But I'm damn glad I lit a fire under your ass.
Where did you get a suitcase full of gold?
And you leave it to me without even showing up?
Debt settled.
You made it!
Get back here right away.
We gotta celebrate.
I repaid my debt.
No!
Oh, hello.
Oh.
He's the actual lone shark.
He's the real lone shark.
It wasn't just a saying.
Hello?
There must be some misunderstanding.
Where do you think you're going with my boat?
forced me to have my associate smash your engine.
That's not very professional of you.
What have I always told you?
Private property is sacred.
Well now you're my property.
I thought I thought I've got a part of the boat.
I'm not public transportation.
You owe me something in return.
Well what can you offer me?
Um, another beer.
A beer?
Pay me back for hauling you to shore?
Give me a break.
I figured you didn't know the true value of things, but now you're just ridiculous.
Sorry, that's not gonna happen.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah, what a night.
I've got every satisfaction I wanted from you.
Part of the crew, part of the ship.
Am I lagging?
A little bit.
Look.
Just in time, too, since my associate was getting impatient.
They couldn't resist coming near the boat he was itching to.
Before we say goodbye, one last question.
Oh, for not to give him just one, make it a good one.
Do you get the moral of the story?
now?
Not just Sarusos.
Your story.
What's the point of me learning a moral of a story if I don't live to learn from it?
Attack him!
I'm gonna attack him.
Put that...
Oh.
Guys.
07.
No!
No, please!
Going towards the moon.
This is a jump scare!
I'm swimming, I'm swimming, I'm swimming, I'm swimming, I'm swimming.
I'm swimming!
What if I just kept swimming forever?
Oh.
Poor Italy.
you listening it happened again it happened again off the coast of one of our most iconic tourist hotspots an angler has vanished boat and all sound familiar maybe because it's the 12th disappearance in 20 years in that area 12 12 and 20 years i wish italy was real really Pickpocketed We got pickpocketed on our boat Oh my god Is this the radio?
Why are they calling me a fucker?
Like always the fucker had to quit a job and got independent Not great with numbers either Rumor has it the fucker borrowed
Is someone gonna gonna crop this out with the fucker right next to me is this how they talk in Italy borrowed from the mob to buy a boat brilliant move right our brave angler disappeared into the thin air authorities think this stop calling me that they've
had health issues and drifted off This fucking fucker Bailed on the debts I paid off my debts What are you talking about?
And left the poor family Drowning in crap This is how they talk in Italy Yeah?
Italian guy?
Meanwhile, poor Italy You're just a little poorer today Uh Maybe that says Tens of thousands of euros Are being poured into searching For this so-called Missing person Tens of thousands of euros.
That cash wasted on a smart ass who... Oh, I said pounds earlier.
It was euros, wasn't it?
I can't tell the difference sometimes.
They look completely different, but my brain switches the two.
Smart ass who almost certainly is sipping a cocktail on some tropical beach.
Sorry, it's cut off a little bit.
Something, don't these kids just go for...
Oh, why don't these kids just go work for someone who knows what they're doing?
Why take out a loan for a boat if you're just gonna sit on it drinking beer?
Truth is, this generation doesn't want to hustle.
I say they've got it coming.
And I'll say this too.
Get a damn job!
Is that the boreal?
Oh.
The moral of the story is to get a job.
Wait, it's over.
That was so fast.
Oh, yeah, Pixabay.
I use them all the time.
I think that's where I got my picture of the lawn, like.
Get a job, they say.
Um.
Thanks for playing.
If I go to the venue.
Wow, we did it.
Moral of the story is to invest in Bitcoin in 2011.
Actually, though.
Wait, that was so fast.
Strange game.
Thanks for the streaming to help you get 400k subscribers by tomorrow.
Why?
What's happening tomorrow?
I'm a streamer.
Is this a...
But mine is a job, too.
Is it calling me out?
Am I?
Am I getting called out?
I feel unemployed sometimes.
Go back and gut him.
So true!
Let's try it.
Let's see if we can gut the guy.
We'll speedrun.
Let's see if we can gut this dude.
early hi okay I'm
a master angler now employing you as court jester yes come to my boat my pretty yes yes there you are actually these fish disgust me they act so high and mighty like they're worth so much money you should just be flopping onto my boat you're worthless acting like you're so much better pulling and and try you know you just why are you acting like you're so good when you're just a little guy you're gonna give me like 10 euro that Good evening!
Thank you for this and for that!
Wait, this unicorn fish is crazy!
It feeds almost exclusively on algae.
Wait, it's crazy!
We could pay off our debts with a million of these.
Alright, I think it's like what?
Probably two fish or so?
one.
Unicorn fish.
I thought it looks like a parrotfish though.
Maybe parrotfish or more.
Every time I see that like little beak, I think of a parrotfish.
Ooh.
Hello.
I'm teasing him too.
I teased too much.
hard to get, you guys.
I give up.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I just didn't want to be seen as, like, too easy.
Oh, man.
This is horrible.
It's fine.
This guy's big.
He's going to be worth a ton.
Great thumbnail, thank you!
Sorry, oh, there we go.
Never knew how much I needed Shark Tooth, black, mascarid, purple-haired Minto in my life.
Play too hard.
You can tease me, Minto?
Really?
How?
How do I tease?
If hungry, it resorts to cannibalism.
Wow.
That's crazy.
You already do?
I do a little bit of teasing.
Hey, did he turn off my music?
Okay.
No, we're speedrunning.
We're speedrunning.
Hey, come on.
Come on.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, you mother effer.
You call me an effer.
you an F-er.
Come on.
God, you're ugly.
You're ugly.
I don't remember your name.
Cag-c-c-c-c-c-c-c-g-l-u-so.
Ugly-us-o.
That's your name.
D-fish.
Come on, D-fish.
You wish you could be D-Dog.
It's like when you catch a magic carp and you're just like, God, this thing's useless.
But D-Dog is Great from the start.
I think she teases us because she kind of likes us.
What are you talking about?
I'm gonna enjoy this.
That hurts!
Angler, you caught me.
Private property is sacred.
Blah, blah.
Oh!
Okay, he probably would have said the same thing, though, no?
I hate the way he looks at me.
I don't think he would have said anything different, though.
Okay, let me try.
Let me try.
Let me try again.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm the worst.
The run is dead.
I can't believe I did that.
Okay, I'll go slower this time.
Okay.
This is kind of nice, though, just the fishing part.
Yeah, I'm going to tease him.
Hey, hey there, big boy.
Oh, oh.
Oh, you like the way I...
Oh.
See, this looks like a parrotfish.
Well, what was it?
The unicorn, I feel like he's got that little...
He's got the little thing on his head, no?
What was with the giant guy in the sea then?
Was that Ceruso?
Was that when he got eaten by the shark?
If he was so big, he could have just crushed the shark himself.
Teased us with that run.
No, this is...
Did they just put the scientific name of this fish in?
It is a poisonous but not lethal fish.
Okay.
Property is sacred.
Property is sacred, little guy.
Why do I have to gut them?
Wouldn't it be more money if I...
Let them do all the work?
Sigma Jarvis.
Here he comes!
Coming in high!
Where is he?
Hello?
Oh, there he is.
Hentai Protag.
It doesn't help that sometimes they accidentally go too high tension.
I get too excited.
I have high tension.
I'm a high tension ghost.
Ghost gal.
Incognito cat.
Thank you so much for the fight.
Get the thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Next guy.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I forgot to tell you.
I don't usually get VTuber stuff on my TikTok at all.
Like, I just kind of like to keep it extremely...
It's mostly like idols and animals.
But if you're watching this...
If you're...
If you're watching this, I saw your TikTok.
Where it was just like, I asked VTubers where to go eat in Japan.
And it was when I said Mossburger, which is great, by the way.
And...
And the guy was like, I went to Mossberger.
Thanks for the gift, the ducky.
I went to Mossberger.
And then people were clowning me in the comments.
I was like, oh, what could people be saying?
They were clowning me in the comments.
They were, they were like, deserve!
No!
They were, first of all, they were like, oh my gosh, This is like, what?
Why?
This is, this, this old person is pro is doing this, this voice for this, what the hell?
Then also mysburger.
Gosh, that's such a, I was like, ooh.
Yowch.
That hurt.
Get it off.
Angler, you've caught me.
I'm a magic fish.
Private property is sacred.
Now I belong to you.
This is the beginning of your fairy tale.
Want to see how it goes?
Gut it.
Not so fast.
Okay, now we learned.
He just poofs away every time.
Yeah, you poof every time.
You tried to gut me?
But I told you I'm magical that it's a fairy tale and all that.
Are you an idiot?
My name is Ka- Uglyuso.
Magic fish, sea vet, and giver of advice.
The illusion of choice.
But then what?
Maybe we gut him, and then we get the phone call that gives us the 45 minutes, and then we just fail.
Okay, once I'm out of this.
Oh, wait, I can still.
Me and Nanyo.
Ah!
Damn, you wear it well.
Oh, the- The text is still there.
He's not a puffer fish.
He's a poofer fish.
That's what I say whenever my cat sees something that gets her freaked out.
I say she's all poofed.
I'm like, what's got you poofed, girl?
What's got you poofed?
Time-saving strat.
Call me the beater, the beta tester.
not as comfy as dredge but still fun also i hope you listen to some more weird outlater i gotta learn that song for saturday should i test it now i don't remember how it goes okay hold on
hardware store i'm gonna sing it with the backing vocals
because i don't remember how it goes at all
Never have been to this town, feel a little down.
The friends told me the news, the news.
You said you don't move, move, move, move.
This is why they're good at building a shop.
Build the parts, bolts, and screws.
Instead, I've been walking on air.
This hair is so excited.
I don't really care.
We're just so since last June.
How happy I'm just to be alive?
I'm not alive.
We inside, well I hope they open to...
I can't wait.
When are they gonna open up that door?
I'm going, yes, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
I'm going to the...
I'm going to the hardware store!
Going to the hardware store!
Let's see if I can't find the door.
Let's see if there's a light up.
The person who was a character to get the guys Had to be here in the night Gonna give me a flashlight, room, and a pair of pliers I'm convinced the person singing this is also not Oh, but I souls?
This person is not singing the lyrics
I can't wait I can't wait I can't wait When are they gonna open up that door?
I'm going, yes, I'm going, yeah, I'm going to the, going to the, going where, going to the, going, going, I'm going to the, going to the hardware store!
Yes, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, going to the, where, I'm going, really, going to the, going, going, going, going, going, going, going, going, going, going, going, going, going, yes, I'm going to the hardware store!
Why did you send me the TikTok?
Oh, this is a good movie.
It was a watch.
Toggy talk, my wires look at this.
I mean, you know, so many details, brother-in-law, sent the two-point room and pick-and-handless coonie with letters.
I understand.
What is, what is the fairly odd pair?
One strip and jump came as hunk and table and the ground table and ladles.
This is the end of the publication, metal roofing, waterproof and molding molding, insulation, air compressors, brass connections, break up with hamster cages, 3% double is how automatic circumcised vacuum cleaners, coffee beaters, calculators, generator smash himself pay for checkers i can't i'm dupes rubber goose
hardware store yeah i'm going this i'm going i'm going to that i'm going hardware store i'm going yes i'm going i'm going to the Going, going to the where, going to, going to, going to, going to the, going to, I'm going to the dresser, I'm going to the hardware.
Really?
Perfect first try.
Why am I lagging so much today?
Oh, maybe I have too much stuff open.
Hardware store.
I thought it was the game, but it's just me.
I'm lagging.
It's the hat.
Yeah, it's the hat.
I wonder if they have fairly odd parents on here.
Song called Albuquerque.
Wait, I think I know that one.
Oh, wait, they actually do.
This is crazy.
Timmy is an average kid, but no one understands.
Mom and Dad and Vicky always giving him commands.
Doom and gloom up in his room is broken instantly.
Buy his magic little fish and grant his every wish.
Cause in reality they are his odd parents, fairly odd parents.
Wants and wings?
Odd parents, fairly odd parents.
Really odd pea pod, love pod, hot rod.
Octus, rubber goose, green moose, jowl shoes, giant snake, birthday cake, large french, chocolate shakes.
Who the hell just interrupted my rap?
Obtuse, rubber goose, green moose, wabajous, giant snake, birthday cake, large fries, chocolate shake!
Yeah, actually, Timmy!
parents then.
Huh?
Hmm?
She sounds just like him.
Danny Phantom?
That's a good one.
Suddenly karaoke.
No, they don't have it on here.
Hold on, I'll find it.
The stream is already dead.
It's already got and got.
What's it called?
Uh.
Oh, Danny.
Phantom.
Then I'm going to go after this.
I actually have a meeting.
But it's Japan time, so it's so late for me.
Oh, pain meds make me drowsy.
Good night!
So, um, what is this?
Oh, here we go.
Does this have lyrics?
Oh, damn it.
Where does it start?
Wait, when does it start?
Apparently, look inside of it.
It was a great big flash.
Everything just changed.
His molecules got all rearranged.
Phantom, phantom.
Did you realize he had growing green eyes?
It was the had to do.
He had to stop all the ghosts that were coming through.
He's here to fight for me and you.
Gotta catch him all cuz he's Danny Phantom Gotta catch him all cuz he's Danny Phantom Gotta catch him all cuz he's Danny Phantom Where did it start?
When does the song start?
I thought it would like cue me in or something
He's a phantom.
Okay, I think I remember now.
Danny Phantom.
Yo, Danny Phantom, he was just 14 When his parents built a very strange machine It was designed to view a world He's gonna catch a wall, cause he is Danny Phantom We didn't quite work, but we just quit Then Danny took a look inside of it There was a great big flash,
everything just changed His molecules got all rearranged Phantom, Phantom First of all, gonna be realized He had snow white hair, glowing green eyes Walk through walls, disappear and fly He was much more unique than the other guys Still Danny knew what he had to do He had to stop all the ghosts that were coming through He's here to fight for me and you!
No, cause he is Danny Phantom Gotta catch a wall, cause he's Danny Phantom Come on, because he's...
Is that song Snake Eater?
Maybe.
Daddy Fat Top.
Snake Eater.
Well, thank you guys for joining me today for a silly, fishy game.
And shorter stream.
I think my computer needs a reset because I'm all laggy.
But I had so much fun and I hope you guys liked seeing lilac a little bit.
Look, you can even see the bags under my eyes.
Pink!
Darko, thank you!
399916.
Oh!
I'm sorry.
It says zoomed out of existence.
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you.
I will see you when I see you next.
And I had a lot of fun.
And this was silly.
I just wanted to play a kind of creepy game.
Mike doesn't say that amount.
Mine says less than that.
Where are you guys getting your numbers from?
I'm the poofer.
Good night, Minky.
Good night.
Thank you.
Otsubito.
Itta-it-a-tai-tai-tai-tai-tai-tai-tai.
Bye-bye.